Stephen where do you see oil heading
right now Trish in the immediate term I
still like the market lower we've been
in a range now and this is dynamics
crude oil contract we're talking about
we've been in a range of between 55 and
forty five dollars just to keep the
numbers around for the past two months
but we're now at a situation where a
crude oil demand is at its weakness
weakest we are in now the refinery
turnaround season the maintenance season
so we're simply not boiling the usual
amount of oil that we will be in say six
and four or five months now you add to
this the potential threat we have from
the USW strike us steel workers strike
on refinery in upwards of 2.6 million
barrels a day of crude oil demand is now
vulnerable to this strike so we have the
situation right now where we don't have
an awesome effects on the oil prices
right I'm sorry baking cookies how is
that affecting oil prices if you don't
have the workers there you know helping
to refine the oil or to get it out of
the ground then theoretically that
should affect demand which should have a
positive effect on oil prices well it
should have a positive effect on one
side of the oil equation right because
if we're putting fewer crude oil bowels
into the refinery because these
refineries are shut down for maintenance
well that about to hit to crude oil
demand and therefore based on oil price
and let me ask you what you're thinking
in terms of prices then we've seen
Goldman say low 40s we've got Gary
Schilling who we all know is very
bearish a lot of the time if not all the
time but gary is saying look we could be
back at ten dollars a barrel which is
the range that we were in back in 99
2000 is that something you're
considering student it's absolutely
possible and we say this because we look
at the way the option prices are being
traded and there's an actual active
market for twenty dollar putts so those
are at is protection of oil gone below
twenty dollars a barrel so it certainly
is possible we're looking at a situation
Trish we have to keep in mind when is
the last time oil prices collapsed
because of good global economic news the
next time Trish will be the first time
so this is the canary in the coal mine
and this should be sending a signal
around the world that everything is not
rainbows in you
horns economically there's a lot of
trouble on the around the world
economically and I believe this is being
reflected even they still go back to
what I've been saying all along that you
know the consumer has not felt connected
to this recovery it has been a recovery
that has helped investors for sure as
the Fed has kept the spigot on with
these incredibly low interest rates and
quantitative easing one two and three
but now perhaps this is the one thing
the consumer needed to feel a little bit
of a break and consumers are gonna have
that much more money in their pockets so
we'll see what the overall effect is we
hope certainly its net positive on the
economy